pas de chaussures pas de chemise vous savez la
personne moyenne qu'ils cherchent à faire un
homme sauvage dans la brousse donc c'est mon
papier toilette je n'ai pas acheté de papier toilette depuis
environ cinq ans c'est agréable et doux c'est
un doux et il a même un  une
très bonne odeur très minimaliste
j'aime garder les choses très simples, donc les
vêtements représentent en quelque sorte qu'il
se débarrasse de tout ce qui est frivole dans la vie
et de tout ce qui est inutile et ne me sert pas,
moi et tout le monde, à un
objectif plus élevé  et c'est cet
exemple ici qui simplifie la vie pour
que je puisse faire ce que je veux plutôt que de
gagner de l'argent pour des choses dont je n'ai pas
vraiment besoin, cela ne me semble pas bien
alors qu'il y a tant de gens dans le
monde qui ne le font pas  j'en ai assez, ça ne me semble pas
juste d'avoir trop
[de musique]
nous vivons à une époque très visuellement
orientée je crois que ce soit la photo ou la
vidéo, les gens ont tendance à faire passer leurs messages à
travers quelque chose de visuel pour que les
choses cliquent dans leur esprit
[Musique]
c'est à peu près  t créer une communauté il s'agit de
rapprocher les gens ce n'est pas
moi moi moi moi vous vous vous vous travaillez
ensemble ici il n'y a pas une seule chose
du supermarché c'est à cent
pour cent de la nourriture que j'ai réellement cultivée dans mon
jardin cet été ou que j'ai forgée  des
arbres fruitiers poussant dans
des terrains abandonnés essentiellement urbains et des parcs
et du sexe, je fais cela parce que c'est une
chose extrême qui amènera les gens à
penser qui inspirera les gens et
j'espère que d'autres personnes ne
sortiront pas et voudront grandir  et forger 100
% de leur nourriture, mon objectif est simplement d'
amener les gens à vouloir faire pousser une chose pour
commencer avec juste un plant de tomate et un
basilic sur leur balcon ou d'avoir un
petit jardin surélevé dans la cour avant pour
commencer quelque part et aider les gens à commencer
ce chemin de se sentir un peu
plus connecté avec notre source de nourriture avec
ce qui nous donne la vie et avec la terre
dans son ensemble